if you're in the market for a killer
mystery featuring some top-shelf acting
talent Netflix has got a movie for you
the unheralded 20/20 feature the night's
clerk has made a strong entrance onto
the streamers top 10 chart debuting at
number 6 the flick stars ty Sheridan is
but a motel clerk with a penchant for
spying on his charges and who sees way
more than he ever wanted to Sheridan
perhaps best known for his lead role in
Steven Spielberg's ready player one and
for portraying the younger version of
Scott Summers and the x-men movies is an
extremely capable young actor the night
clerk surrounds him with an excellent
supporting cast which includes anna de
Armas Helen Hunt and John Leguizamo the
film was written and directed by Michael
Christopher who in the late 70s won a
Pulitzer Prize and a Tony Award for his
Broadway stage production the shadow box
he's penned screenplays for flicks like
The Witches of Eastwick and the bonfire
of the vanities directed movies such as
gia and original sin and even appeared
as an actor in a slew of television
series and feature films most recently
he appeared as Philip price in the hits
USA series mr. robots the night clerk is
Christopher's first turn in the
director's chair since 2001 and for
Netflix viewers it's hitting the sweet
spot in the film Sheridan's Bart as a
young man who lives with Asperger's
syndrome he works a lonely night ship on
the Mercer hotels front desk secretly he
sets up five surveillance cameras in one
of the rooms in order to try to gain a
better understanding of how to engage
people in conversation and alleviate his
own social awkwardness one night a woman
named Karen checks in and bath gives her
his wired room he completes his shift
and goes home where he watches Karen
unexpectedly a man shows up and that's
when everything starts to go pear-shaped
for but there's a violent altercation
and Bars makes the unfortunate decision
to return to the hotel and try to help
Karen the young woman ends up dead of a
gunshot wound with Bart apparently the
only person thereby from there things
only get twistier and we won't spoil
what happens next you might be asking
yourself how you've never heard of this
movie before well that's a very
complicated question the night clerk
failed to secure theatrical distribution
on its release the flick was released
directly to VOD platforms in February
2020 with virtually no advertising or
promotion to speak off with a
many of us still staying at home
whenever possible due to the ongoing
corona virus pandemic a lot of obscure
movies are getting their shots at the
spotlight and in the case of the night
clerk audiences are liking what they're
seeing the movie was only just released
to Netflix on June 6th and it took
virtually no time at all for it to
become one of the streamers most watched
titles there's a reason for that it's a
nifty little murder mystery
featuring excellent performances from
Sheridan and Damas two actors who stars
are decidedly on the rice you can catch
Sheridan next in the sci-fi thriller
voyages which is expected to be released
in November of 2020 the armours will
next appear in the 25th James Bond film
no time to die also slated for release
in November although the night clerk has
climbed its way up the Netflix rankings
ladder
it's at the lower end of the scale when
it comes to critical reviews the flick
has a rotten score on the review
aggregator Rotten Tomatoes and this
critical consensus paints it as having a
quote poorly conceived story and not
even its quote a pair of charismatic
leads can bring to life still while the
night clerk may not have poured in rave
reviews it's certainly poured of viewers
in on Netflix potentially by the
millions there must be a reason for that
so why not check it out for yourself and
if you end up disappointed thankfully
there are a ton of other mystery movies
to watch on Netflix check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favourite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]